[Music]
on this sunday night
ontario's top doctor retires and the
pandemic isn't over
[Music]
did acrimony between david williams and
doug ford
lead to the early departure a whole
bunch of red flags went up
i mean what's going on plus the resume
and record
of his replacement the oil sands
outbreak how the virus overwhelmed
workers in alberta
operation hubs eliminating the backlog
of surgeries
because of the pandemic and the horrific
history of residential schools
how canada is remembering the children
lost
national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with a shake-up in
ontario public health
the province is replacing its top doctor
even though the covet 19 health crisis
still isn't over dr david williams was
always set to retire but he delayed his
departure because of the pandemic
and critics are wondering why now our
ottawa correspondent michael couture
is looking into this mike
robin the news of dr david williams's
departure has ontario opposition
mpps asking a lot of questions about the
timing
and the reason behind it a whole bunch
of red flags went up i mean
what's going on the ontario ndp health
critic was blindsided by the news
especially since dr david williams had
indicated he was willing to push back
his february retirement date
and stay on until september franz jalina
points out former general rick hillier
was hired on a short contract
to handle ontario's vaccine rollout but
he decided not to stay on longer
and as the vaccination had not even
reached a million ontarian
there he was gone the ontario government
did not respond to our request for an
interview but in a statement health
minister christine elliott
thanks dr williams for his years of
service and praised his work
premier doug ford has often done the
same but he hasn't always been on the
same page
as his chief medical officer of health
most recently
on children returning to school it would
be great if the
students in my mind could be back in for
those three to four weeks before
the summer break so we want to be very
very cautious the science table
has said that we open the schools these
numbers are going up
to some infectious disease experts there
was often a disconnect between premier
ford and dr williams
even though we were told that a lot of
the evidence was a lot of the decisions
were based on
what the science table was saying or
other experts were saying
i didn't see evidence of this in many of
the policies
dr williams replacement will be dr
kieran moore who is kingston's officer
of medical health
they've only had three deaths in that
entire region related to cova 19.
and really that's a testament to his
leadership
doctors moore and williams are expected
to work side by side for the next few
weeks to ensure
a seamless transition and dr williams's
last day
is june 25th robin mike liquiteur in
ottawa thanks mike
more than 8 000 oil sands workers have
now received the first dose of vaccine
in a province working to contain
outbreaks of coba 19. in recent months
the virus has swept through more than a
dozen of these work sites in alberta
infecting thousands as heather york west
explains
the blame is being put on a federal
government exemption
the variant fueled third wave hit
canada's oil sands workers hard
infecting nearly 3 000 people in two
outbreaks alone
at canadian natural resources horizon
mine site
and the mildred lake site operated by
syncrude
by may there were more than 1300 cases
at mildred lake
horizon had more than fifteen hundred
three workers there
died according to both companies strict
coveted safety protocols were in place
including rapid testing and mask
requirements
but both cnrl horizon and syncrude
mildred lake
also proceeded with spring maintenance
projects
it meant 5 000 additional skilled
workers were brought to the horizon site
2 000 more to syncrude mildred lake i do
believe it probably is connected
to travel with workers coming in
from out of the province and out of the
country workers traveling to the oil
sense from out of country were given a
federal
exemption from the 14-day quarantine
requirement
syncrude brought about 60 workers from
outside canada
in all but a handful of cases the
company says it required a 14-day
quarantine
anyways but at cnrl another 60 workers
brought up from the u.s
were not required to quarantine at all a
company spokesperson says
all federal and provincial requirements
for sectors designated as essential
services
were followed if they're providing
exemptions and then there's
outbreaks i mean there's a pretty
obvious link between the two
with thousands of workers now partially
immunized outbreak numbers are coming
down
but after so many infections several
workers still in hospital
and four dead many questions remain
heather urex west global news calgary
throughout this pandemic canada's health
care system hasn't had a break and
there's still the backlog of surgeries
that were canceled
hospitals are under immense pressure to
cut down the wait list
but how as mike chile reports one
proposal from across the pond
might offer a solution
with covet 19 numbers in decline ontario
hospitals are looking to make up for
lost time
but there's only so many hours in a day
and the backlog of surgeries canceled
because of the pandemic
is staggering we can't have people
working flat out 24 7.
it may be necessary to increase service
volumes
by some degree that may be necessary
over the foreseeable future
no province saw its wait list for
non-urgent surgical cases increase as
much as ontario
with the current estimate around 440 000
surgeries
nationally the picture isn't all bad
news bc cleared out most of its wait
list by having surgeries at night
and on weekends alberta is looking to
private clinics to help it catch up
and in ontario the current plan is
similar to bcs
but a provincial committee crunched the
numbers and came to the conclusion it
would take three and a half years to
clear the backlog
the uk has a similar problem on a larger
scale
with a backlog of an estimated 5 million
surgeries it's a massive problem that's
led to an innovative proposal
the creation of surgical hubs that
specialize in specific areas
like knee replacements the idea is to
become more efficient
but canadian healthcare leaders worry it
could lead to bigger problems
we don't want to sanction these things
for a short period of time
and then you know create almost like an
assembly line effect where
we're just pumping through volume
without really a lot of quality measures
in place
because that's another detriment to
health and health care overall as well
the problem with canadian health care
say experts
is that it's not efficient and that's
nothing new
wait times vary from doctor to doctor
even if they work in the same field
it's a situation where everybody knows
what the right answer is
what he's referring to is the single
entry system
similar to the queue at customs one line
that leads to all the experts
this is a generational opportunity to
you know to take advantage of a crisis
to create health system reform that were
absolutely critical
before the pandemic hit studies have
shown a single entry system could
improve wait times
by up to thirty percent it would be a
big change
but are we ready for it mike droli
global news toronto
the acting head of canada's military
says he's committed to making sure
victims of sexual misconduct
feel they can speak out lieutenant
general wayne ayer appeared on this
week's edition of the west block
his first tv interview since taking
command of the canadian armed forces in
february
air shut down operation honor a mission
that several victims felt had been
poisoned
by the allegations of sexual misconduct
facing the military
the lieutenant general says the top
brass hopes to learn from the failures
of operation honor
but right now supporting victims is the
top priority
the real tragedy is we have uh
complainants who have
carried uh the pain of what has happened
in the past for decades
and so helping them supporting them
achieve closure has
absolutely have to be it has to be at
the top of the list in
in helping us get through this
and you can watch the full interview
later this evening on the west block
right here on global in the u.s tonight
house democrats say there will be a
congressional inquiry into the january
6th riot on the capitol
even after senate republicans voted to
block an independent commission to
investigate
democrats claim republicans are still
trying to protect former president
donald trump
who's accused of inciting the riot and
it's all happening as texas moves to
pass strict voter laws
with the belief that voter fraud cost
trump the election
jennifer johnson reports
democrats and some republicans vow to
get answers as to who organized the mob
that stormed the u.s capitol january 6.
even after senate republicans blocked an
independent commission's investigation
what we really need to know is what was
donald trump doing
in the hours before the riot during the
riot
what was he talking to or telling his
advisors democrats are pushing for a
bipartisan committee with subpoena
powers to get answers
some republicans say the vote was a slap
in the face to capitol police officers
who risked their lives to save u.s
lawmakers our officers are hurting right
now people need to know that those
capital officers that they walk by
every day they want a commission they
are hurting they are leaving in droves
critics charged senate republicans are
trying to protect former president trump
who encouraged the mob to stop the
certification of the election
claiming he was the victim of voter
fraud we will stop
the steal backing that baseless claim
texas republicans are now
on the verge of passing new voter
restrictions following similar laws
passed by georgia and florida
it's going to disproportionately impact
people of color you have to understand
the damage that you're causing
the texas bill gives partisan poll
watchers more power
adds new id requirements for mail-in
ballots cuts back early voting hours
and makes it easier to overturn election
results since the election
republican-backed
measures making voting more difficult
have been introduced in 43 states
despite protests the texas bill is
expected to pass
and signed into law by governor greg
abbott a longtime
trump supporter jennifer johnson global
news washington
coming up german researchers may have an
explanation for the vaccines causing
blood clots
there are still questions surrounding
the safety of the astrazeneca and
johnson and johnson vaccines
that's because of the extremely rare but
serious blood clots reported in some
patients
now german researchers believe they know
why there's this potentially deadly side
effect
and how it can be prevented crystal
commansing explains
it's one of the most significant
mysteries in modern medicine
and it's gripping scientists and
spurring research that's unfolding
in real time why vector vaccines like
astrazeneca and johnson and johnson
have resulted in extremely rare cases
of blood clotting the key may be how
these shots
enter the body on a cellular level and
teach it to recognize the virus that
causes covid19 german researchers
theorized the rare events
could be the result of vector vaccines
sending dna
information into the nucleus of cells
and not the cell
fluid inside the nucleus it's converted
into rna before it leaves the cell
possibly without all of the information
being transferred
biochemistry and biomedical associate
professor matthew miller
says the findings are plausible the cell
can make
some changes to the mrna such that
the spike protein of sars kobe 2 no
longer
stays attached to the cell that's making
it
but instead gets secreted
into the bloodstream for example
thromboembolic events associated with
the vaccines led to numerous reviews by
drug regulators
all found the vaccines to be safe still
people became fearful of the rare side
effects
what the authors of this study proposed
doesn't really explain
why these rare people experience this
outcome and not
everyone the vaccine manufacturers are
investigating the causes of the rare
blood clotting events
while the german research which has not
been peer reviewed
doesn't provide all of the answers it's
a start says jonathan ball
if you can tweak the sequence of the
gene that you've delivered into the
nucleus it might be possible to stop
that processing from happening and
therefore potentially prevents those
altered gene products those altered
proteins from being produced
more work is still needed but these
findings could lead to improvements with
this current generation of vaccines
as well as future shots bring it on
bring it on
crystal glancing global news london
our next story is about misconduct
allegations against a former
high-ranking mountie
allegations that recently surfaced
during a murder investigation
in british columbia it's raised
questions not only about
how that case was handled but how rcmp
investigated
one of their own so who's policing the
police
jules knox reports on the calls to
reform the system
senior ranking mountie brian gately had
the phone of a dead woman
hacked into by a colleague using rcmp
equipment he did so as a favor to a
personal acquaintance
her husband who said he wanted its
photos from the couple's last day
together
rcmp launched a code of conduct
investigation into gately over the hack
and over a potential conflict of
interest for allegedly giving his
personal opinion to officers
investigating her death
but the allegations against gately did
not go to a public conduct hearing
gately resigned well what happens is
it's it's over
as soon as they resign the act the files
declared
closed nothing happens in september rcmp
said that when an officer resigns
they're no longer subject to code of
conduct and any ongoing investigations
would cease but they backtracked this
week clarifying that the investigation
is finished but those findings aren't
made public
in a letter to the women's family gately
admits he had the phone unlocked
but after rcmp returned it to the
husband as police were still treating
her death as an
accident it was before the murder
investigation began
gately says he was not involved in the
case and denies his actions had any
impact on the investigation or the
prosecution
others aren't so sure the actions of
gately were such that it does
call into question whether he obstructed
justice
although rcmp became aware of the
allegations against gately in december
of 2017
that conduct letter wouldn't be written
for another nine
months it was finally signed by
assistant commissioner kevin hackett
who also happened to be the chief
officer of bc's organized crime agency
at the time
where gately landed his next job it is
simply you know birds of a feather flock
together they stick together
gately and hackett declined global's
requests for interviews
but this is not an isolated story from
2009 to 2016
more than a quarter of mounties facing
conduct investigations resigned
criminology professor daryl davies says
there's a serious lack of accountability
and a hidden cost for taxpayers if
you've been charged you can write out
the time for months
if not years suspended with pay and then
days before your trial is due
simply resign even former mounties are
demanding change
i think suspension with it without pay
for a serious
uh grievous offense that should be
automatic
i actually would not have police
investigating place
there must be an oversight body that has
teeth
that can actually enforce what they're
doing
canada's public safety minister would
not comment on calls for legislative
changes
at the end of the day the police even
investigate the police
i mean it is i hate to say it but it's
farcical
it's been going on like that for years
and he adds
too often it's the victim not the
officer who ultimately pays the price
jules knox global news kelowna bc
up next old wounds reopened after the
discovery of a suspected mass grave
why canada's dark chapter isn't over yet
flags are flying at half-mast across the
country for what is believed to be a
mass grave in bc
the chief of the tekemploops first
nation says the remains of as many as
215 children
were located on the property of an old
residential school
the practice of taking indigenous
children from their families is forever
a dark chapter in canada's history and
the deep pain
persists but as roslord reports there
are calls to move forward
with reconciliation if making sense of
it is impossible
canadians are at least trying to do
something about what happened at this
former residential school for indigenous
children
among the tributes across canada many
symbolize the number 215
the estimated number of children whose
remains have been discovered in
unmarked graves according to the tikkem
loop's first nation
flags are being lowered including at
ottawa's peace tower and at other
government
buildings there are calls for a national
day of mourning
from those who consider these tributes
only the beginning
we're going to most likely be bringing
them home which means
potentially unearthing them and going
through and identifying them
and then seeing which community they
belong to
so that's going to be so hard and so
horrendous
i felt grief you know
and and i felt a little bit
angry as well you know and i'm not an
angry person
by nature this first nations chief
suggests
only after a long period of reflection
has he
managed to find anything positive these
children's herd is gone
their pain is gone they're at peace
this is now about what we do to remember
this moment
but also how do we go forward from here
there are other questions how to fit the
discovery into the already disgraceful
history of residential schools
and into the pursuit of reconciliation
how to help our own children understand
it
especially indigenous students who live
with the repercussions
generations later as canadians look for
new ways and new symbols to honor the
children and their families
the full magnitude of the horror is
unknown
the tekem's first nation says
preliminary findings should be completed
by mid-june
it promises updates as they become
available ross lord
global news and that is global national
for this sunday night
i'm robin gill we leave you tonight with
more tributes from around the country
for the countless children lost in the
residential school system
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow
good night
you